hello I'm gravity a student of
electronics and communication your
invention has been successfully
implemented in mp3 players and other
things how do you feel when you see that
your inventions have had immediate
applications yes a good question what I
feel is that science and research walk
this is my main conclusions I was not
completely convinced at the beginning of
the carrier but now I see that this
research works well and that means that
you can start you mind some scenario
with electron spins you can be skeptical
at the beginning that finally I saw that
after this abstract construction in the
mind can become concrete experiments and
finally concrete device that everybody
use in the shops in the interest rate on
computer or elsewhere so my feeling is
that the research is a powerful tool do
and that transforming or the product of
your imagination in device that you can
use in your daily life